قالت واشنطن ان ارسالها مقاتلات وبرجه
حربيه الى الشرق الاوسط هدفه ردع ما سمته
اي عدوان ايراني محتمل كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
المؤشرات التي تستند اليها واشنطن في
حديثها عن عدوان الايراني المحتمل في
منطقه الخليج ما مدى واقعيه نشر الولايات
المتحده جنودا على السفن التجاريه في مضيق
هرمز ما بدا ارتباط هذه الخطوه بلقاء قائد
الاسطول الامريكي الخامس بالامين العام
لمجلس مجلس لدول مجلس التعاون الخارجي
[موسيقى]
هناك شعور بان لو ان الولايات المتحده
تكون موجوده مباشره على متن السفن
التجاريه وقريبه منها هذا سيرضع ايران
منها طبعا ايران لم ترتدع من قبل فواشن
تشعر انها بحاجه لتعزيز وجودها الشيء
المعلن هو هذا الذي تفضلت به من اجل
مراقبه سير الملاحه البحريه في مضيق هرمز
والمياه الخليجيه وفي المحيط الشمال
المحيط الهندي اداره اي احتكاك محتمل يمكن
ان يكون في هذه المنطقه اصل التواجد
الامريكي والتعزيز الامريكي في هذه
المنطقه اني لا اعتقد بانه يخص حركه
الملاحه لانه يستهدف شيء اخر
نهضم ثابت الرد على عدوان ايران والذي
تمثل في بيع مسيرات لروسيا
[موسيقى]
ستكون بمثابه تصعيد وسوف يكون وضع اي جنود
عسكريين امريكيين على متن سفن تجاريه هذه
السفن ليست محميه وليست مدرعه وبالامكان
ان تهاجم من قبل قوات الحرس الثوري
وقواربه
المنتشره هناك وربما هناك احتمال ايضا ان
يتم اسر افراد عسكريين امريكيين او
استعراض القوه الامريكيه وهو ليس له مبرر
في اعتقاده يعني امريكا تريد ان يكون لها
وجود ما عندها استراتيجيه واضحه في الشرق
الاوسط حمايه اسرائيل فقط الحلفاء
الخليجيين منذ سنوات نشعر
بالتراجع الامريكي والانكفاء ايرانيين
يعني يريدون ان يكون في يكونوا في جهزيه
عاليه من اجل مواجهه اي احتمالات او اي
مفاجاه محتمله في هذه المنطقه ارسال 2000
مارينز وبحار وطائف 165
وبارجه ومدمره وسفن انزال هذا لا يعوض
التراجع الامريكي والانكفاء والاتجاه نحو
الخليج وخاصه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ودوله الامارات العربيه
بدات في الماضي القريب بالشك في مدى
التزامي الولايات المتحده بامن الخليج
امريكا تصاعد بشكل كبير وايران ترد ايضا
بشكل مستفز في مناورات في الجزر
الاماراتيه المحتله
الصغرى وابو موسى وتشتبك مع الكويت
والسعوديه حول حول حقل الدره ايران عازمه
على تعميق وتعزيز علاقاتها مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وفيما يخص حقل الدره لحد
الان ايران لم تقل بانها لا تريد ان تحل
المشاكل العالقه في في ترسيم الحدود مع
دوله الكويت بطرق غير سلميه وغير سياسيه
على العكس من ذلك تولد شعورا لدى السعوديه
والامارات بان الولاده المتحده تغ المنطقه
وتهتم بالصين اكثر عندما لم تزود امريكا
المنطقه بالسلاحه يانا وعندما لم تحمي
الرئيس مبارك السعوديه والامارات بدات
تشعر بان الولايات المتحده لم تعد معنيه
بحمايه الخليج والدفاع عنه ضد ايران على
ايران ايضا ان تعيد التفكير بحساباتها لم
يمضي اربعه اشهر على المصالحه والتقارب مع
السعوديه وايران وتبدو ايران الان انها
نفضت يعني غزها وبدات عادت الى السياسه
التي فيها استفزاز وفيها مواجهه هذه
الخطوه الامريكيه خطه استفزازيه ربما تريد
ان اقول ربما تريد ان تستهدف اي تعاون
محتمل بين ايران ودول الدول الخليجيه او
التحالف البحري او
التعاون والتنسيق بين الجانبين وكان هذا
ربما اشاره من الولايات المتحده لتعزيز
وجودها وارسال المزيد من القوات وان وضع
جنود على متن السفن تجاريه سوف يؤكد
لبلدان الخليج للشعوب الخليج بان الولايات
المتحده شكرا تم بامن الخليج زياده القوات
العديد القوات الامريكيه لطمان الدول
الخليفه الدرجه الاولى
والنقطه الثانيه ايضا لارسال رساله لدول
الخليج بان ليس من مصلحه دول الخليج
التحالف مع الصين في عقر دار النفود
الامريكي